[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the best ancillary part of
the last two days is Trump still doesn't
seem to realize that his former campaign
manager is being indicted under a stack
of charges including conspiracy against
the United States of America Trump also
doesn't seem to realize that Bob Muller
has an informant one of the first five
names Trump ever announced on his
foreign policy team who says the
Russians offered him dirt on Hillary
Clinton and thousands of Clinton emails
and tried to get Trump to meet with
Putin directly Trump also doesn't seem
to realize that while the mana Ford
indictment never mentions Trump's name
there is that little phrase at the end
about mana Ford and gates quotes
together with others knowingly and
intentionally conspired to defraud the
United States together with others
others like Papadopoulos is European
professor and the female Russian
national if he's the professor she's
either Mary Ann or ginger like Kushner
Trump jr. Flynn Paige Bannon the
Mercer's the entire Cambridge analytic
astable there's potentially all sorts of
fish out there to indict later as mana
forts squirms and developments warrant
and then there is the other possibility
the mega indictment possibility the mo
AC the mo AK possibility the mother of
all Christmases I will defer entirely to
Barbara McQuade former US Attorney for
the Eastern District of Michigan now law
professor at the University of Michigan
last Friday night writing for The Daily
Beast she quietly dropped this bomb one
extreme scenario is that the sealed
indictment charges President Trump
himself it is possible that Muller has
had sufficient time to complete his
investigation of obstruction of justice
against the president the obstruction
case would involve a somewhat isolated
series of events that are less complex
than the larger interference
investigation while the law is unclear
under DOJ policy a sitting president
cannot be held to answer to criminal
charges in court
and may only be impeached one way to
handle that scenario is to indict him
now seal the indictment and unseal it on
the day he leaves office by impeachment
or otherwise in light of the
complexities and importance of the case
however it seems unlikely that Muller
has reached this point yet Wow on the
subject of including a sitting president
in an indictment in February 1974 the
Watergate grand jury told my prosecutors
that it could not indict Richard Nixon
did secretly include him in other
indictments listing him as an unindicted
co-conspirator a special prosecutor who
brought Nixon down second one Leon
Jaworski later said he actually used the
threat of exposing Nixon's unindicted
co-conspirator status as leverage to get
the White House to release some of the
Watergate tapes so Muller acting in some
way directly against Trump is still on
this table there is something else
former US attorney McQuaid wrote that
you should consider for whenever further
indictments are handed up handed down or
handed over Justice Department policy
states clearly that it's not enough just
to get a grand jury to indict the
proverbial ham sandwich that you can
only file charges if there is a
reasonable likelihood of a conviction at
a trial if you indict them in other
words you'd better be able to get a jury
to convict them or if they're unindicted
co-conspirators you better have
significant justification for naming
them such as evidence that you intend to
submit that ties them to the indicted
parties so until the next shoes drop
professor keep your mind occupied
however you best can me I like to watch
this From Russia With Love
Trump FBI raid mashup video by the guy
with the Twitter handle one one clone
that I keep tweeting about I like to
watch it like every two hours or so or
you can just read this one tweet aloud
as if it was sent by a terrified man
stuck in quicksand
do something yeah do
something specifically resists remove
piece now you could just buy my book
based on these commentaries will be
working on a version in Russian that you
can send to the professor